j'ai l'honneur aujourd'hui de présenter
devant votre assemblée avec le ministre
de l'action des comptes publics gérald
darmanin qui malheureusement ne peut pas
être là cet après midi le premier projet
de loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale de cette mandature se paie des
faits c'est un texte dense et un texte
qui fait des choix
c'est le choix du pouvoir d'achat pour
les salariés par la baisse des
cotisations sociales et par
l'augmentation au 1er octobre prochain
de la prime d'activité c'est le choix de
conforter notre modèle de protection
sociale en adaptant son financement à
l'évolution de notre économie de notre
société et en renforçant son une
universalité afin que chacun puisse
bénéficier de la même sécurité sociale
quel que soit son statut professionnel
c'est le choix j'y reviendrai de la
solidarité au bénéfice de nos
concitoyens les plus fragiles qu'il
s'agisse des bénéficiaires du minimum
vieillesse ou des familles les plus
pauvres
choisir c'est aussi assumer une
politique de prévention ambitieuse qui
protège nos concitoyens et prendre à
bras le corps la première des inégalités
en matière de santé
l'inégalité devant la prévention faire
des choix s'est également posée dès
maintenant les jalons pour une
transformation continue et résolue des
modalités de tarification des actes et
des prestations qui incite à privilégier
la pertinence et la qualité et qui
prenne en compte les besoins des
patients dans leur globalité les choix
que ce plfss vous propose sont ceux
d'une france qui porte haut
l'ambition d'un modèle de protection
sociale et d'un modèle de santé
solidaire d'un modèle qui permette
l'égal accès aux soins et à l'innovation
pour tous qui garantissent l'équité des
citoyens devant la retraite et qui
répondent efficacement aux besoins
prioritaires des familles ces choix ne
sont possibles ces choix ne sont
crédibles mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs que si nous nous donnons les
moyens de rétablir l'équilibré des
comptes de la sécurité sociale
et je sais votre assemblée très
attentive à cet objectif en tant que
ministre des solidarités je suis
particulièrement attaché à ce que nos
concitoyens puissent avoir durablement
confiance dans leur système de
protection sociale et sans équilibre des
comptes
il n'y a pas de confiance possible à
moyen et long terme 2010cette verra des
comptes de la sécurité sociale
s'améliorer de 2,6 milliards d'euros par
rapport à 2016 avec toutefois un déficit
encore important de 2,5 pendant de 5,2
milliards d'euros en 2018 le déficit
devrait à nouveau se réduire de 3
milliards d'euros par rapport à 2017
c'est une trajectoire en ligne avec
l'objectif fixé par le premier ministre
dans son discours de politique générale
d'un retour à l'équilibré à l'horizon
2020 suivre ce chemin exigeant c'est
aussi faire des choix mais c'est ouvrir
à nos concitoyens la perspective
nouvelle de la fin du déficit de la
sécurité sociale
et c'est offrir aux jeunes générations
une protection sociale débarrasser de la
dette sociale accumulée au cours des 20
dernières années
je souhaite mesdames et messieurs
revenir plus précisément sur les
orientations que porte ce plfss
ce plfss c'est le plfss de la solidarité
il s'adresse en effet d'abord aux
personnes aux familles les plus en
difficulté et pour lesquels la
solidarité nationale doit jouer en
priorité ma première préoccupation ce
sont les personnes âgées les plus
pauvres elles sont plus d'un demi
million en france à vivre avec 800 euros
par mois
nous augmenterons donc le minimum
vieillesse 200 euros par mois
conformément aux engagements du
président de la république
cela commencera dès le 1er avril
prochain avec une augmentation de 30
euros
l'augmentation sera ensuite de 35 euros
en janvier 2019 et 35 euros en janvier
2020 un mi mandat le minimum vieillesse
europe donc augmenté de plus de 12%
je veux aussi répondre aux besoins des
personnes âgées en perte d'autonomie et
poursuivre l'adaptation des ehpad en
renforçant l'encadrement soignants
4500 places d'hébergement permanent être
près de 1500 places d'accueil de jour ou
d'hébergement temporaires seront créés
100 millions d'euros seront consacrés au
renforcement de l'encadrement soignants
j'ai souhaité par ailleurs soutenir au
travers du plfss
le déploiement progressif d'astreinte
infirmières la nuit ce dispositif permet
un meilleur traitement des problèmes qui
peuvent survenir la nuit et invite ainsi
des hospitalisations inutiles dont on
sait qu'elles sont toujours très
délétère pour les personnes dépendantes
et fragile
ce plfss s'adresse aussi aux familles je
veux mettre en adéquation les priorités
et les outils de la politique familiale
avec les besoins des familles notre pays
se distingue de longue date par
l'importance qu'il attache à une
politique familiale large et structurer
cette politique affiche des réussites
manifeste un taux de fécondité parmi les
plus élevés d'europe
une participation des femmes au marché
du travail relativement forte et une
conciliation entre vie familiale et vie
professionnelle qui doit encore
progresser mais qui est facilitée par
une offre d'accueil du jeune enfant
substantielle diverses et financièrement
accessible mais je fais aussi le constat
que la politique familiale est
aujourd'hui en perte de repères quant à
ses finalités et ses priorités et que le
nombre de naissances est en baisse
depuis plusieurs années la politique
familiale est un élément essentiel pour
faire société et construire le monde de
demain
elle mérite je crois que nous ayons un
débat ouvert large sur la façon dont
elles répondent aujourd'hui concrètement
aux attentes des familles comment
augmenter et améliorer les solutions de
garde des jeunes enfants et prendre
mieux en compte des besoins des parents
qui travaillent ou recherchent un emploi
comment aider les familles en
difficultés éducatives et être plus
efficace dans le soutien à la
parentalité
comment contribuer à réduire des
situations de pauvreté
la france compte aujourd'hui trois
millions d'enfants vivant dans un foyer
dont les revenus se situent en dessous
du seuil de pauvreté
cette réalité nous devons nous en saisir
pour la faire évoluer et c'est pour moi
une priorité
ce premier plfss fait un choix très
clair celui d'augmenter les prestations
à destination des familles les plus
fragiles les familles nombreuses les
plus pauvres bénéficieront de la hausse
du complément familial majoré au 1er
avril 2018
cela concernera quatre cent cinquante
mille familles pour les familles
monoparentales qui sont souvent parmi
les plus en difficulté le montant de
l'allocation de soutien familial sera
revalorisé au 1er avril également et 750
mille familles seront donc conservé le
montant maximal maximal de l'aide à la
garde d'enfant pour les parents qui
recourt à un assistant maternel une
garde à domicile ou une microcrèche
augmentera de 30% ce plfss fait des
choix et certains de ces choix peuvent
faire débat mais il s'inscrit résolument
dans une perspective plus large celle
d'une concertation mené en 2018 avec
l'ensemble des parties prenantes avec
les organisations familiales avec les
parlementaires et également pardon
également pour redéfinir les objectifs
assignés à notre politique familiale se
paie l'effet st-gelais indiqué est aussi
un peu l'effet cesse de transformation
il engage les évolutions structurelles
pour les années à venir
cette ambition de réformes concernent
d'abord l'organisation de la protection
sociale ou le savez le 1er janvier 2018
le rsi sera adossée au régime général
cette réforme part du constat largement
partagé que le lien de confiance entre
les indépendants et leurs régimes de
sécurité sociale a été durablement
altérée par les difficultés de mise en
oeuvre et mise en place de
l'interlocuteur social unique depuis
cette réforme s'inscrit aussi dans la
perspective d'une sécurité sociale
universelle qui vise à simplifier les
démarches des citoyens quelle que soit
leur parcours professionnel salarié ou
travailleur indépendant ou leur statut
je pense notamment aux étudiants elle
est donc une nouvelle étape
de construction de notre système de
protection sociale est une forme de
retour aux sources de l'ambition des
fondateurs de la sécurité sociale en
je vous c'est digitimes ans très
attentif aux conditions de mise en
oeuvre de la réforme parce que c'est une
réforme ambitieuse
nous donnons le temps et les moyens
nécessaires à la transformation
vous le savez au 1er janvier 2018 une
période de transition de deux ans sera
ouverte
cette période permettra de faire évoluer
progressivement des organisations de
travail et de mener un dialogue social
de qualité avec les salariés et leurs
représentants
je veux redire à cet égard devant vous
mon attention à l'accompagnement social
et professionnel des salariés du rsi
comme ceux des organismes conventionnés
qui servent les prestations d'assurance
maladie cette période de transition est
nécessaire elle sera même un peu plus
long pour la reprise de l'activité des
organismes conventionnés qui
n'interviendra qu'en 2020 elle ne doit
pas être prolongée au delà de façon à
donner aux organisations et aux
personnels un cadre pérenne de travail
elle n'impose pas en revanche de date
butoir
s'agissant de l'évolution des systèmes
d'informations le gouvernement est
particulièrement attentif à ce que
l'organisation mise en place permettent
une évolution graduée est maîtrisée de
ces systèmes dans des conditions de
sécurité garantie je veux enfin dire
l'attachement du gouvernement à ce que
au sein du régime général
la spécificité de la situation des
travailleurs indépendants soit reconnue
de façon à adapter le service qui
l'aurait rendu l'ambition de
transformation concerne également notre
système de retraite
le président de la république s'est
engagé à faire évoluer notre système de
retraite pour le rendre plus juste et
plus transparent
la rénovation de notre système de
retraites devra répondre à plusieurs
enjeux majeurs elle redonnera de la
lisibilité à un système qui sont
construits qui s'est construit par
strates successives et qui est
aujourd'hui devenu complexe et opaque
pour les français elle devra également
assurer la pérennité de notre système de
retraite
rétablir la confiance que lui porte nos
concitoyens en particulier s'agissant
des jeunes elle permettra de redonner
confiance à nos concitoyens dans son
équité aujourd'hui compte tenu de la
diversité des régimes et des règles un
euro cotisé n'ouvre pas les mêmes droits
selon le statut la forme d'emploi ou
encore le profil de la carrière de
l'assuré
cette réforme permettra donc de garantir
une équité de traitement entre
l'ensemble des assurés enfin le devra
permettre à chacun de mener des
carrières nécessairement plus
diversifiée qu'elles ne l'ont été dans
le passé entre statuer régime sans
craindre l'impact de ses choix sur ses
droits à la retraite
ce projet ambitieux nous le mènerons
avec jean paul delevoye le haut
commissaire à la réforme des retraites
dans le cadre d'une démarche exemplaire
de concertation avec l'ensemble des
parties prenantes l'ambition de
transformation concerne enfin le champ
de la santé
je construis vous le savez la stratégie
nationale de santé pour les cinq
prochaines années je ferai connaître en
décembre les orientations précises que
je retiens au terme de plusieurs mois de
consultations et d'une grande
concertation publique qui s'est ouverte
mardi dernier ces orientations serviront
de cadre à l'élaboration d'un plan
national de santé et de plans régionaux
de santé au printemps
cette stratégie privilégie quatre axes
la prévention l'égal accès aux soins
l'innovation et la pertinence et la
qualité des soins je souhaite évoquer
d'abord la prévention parce qu'elle est
au centre de mon action
notre système de santé est un système de
soins performants
c'est en revanche un système de
prévention défaillant à tout le moins
perfectible les résultats médiocres que
nous affichons pour certains indicateurs
je pense notamment à la mortalité avant
l'âge de 65 ans illustre cette
défaillance
c'est aussi la principale source des
inégalités sociales que notre système de
santé ne parvient pas à corriger
nous devons avoir comme première
priorité de changer cet état de fait de
systématiser les démarches de prévention
dès le plus jeune âge de faire en sorte
qu'elle soit davantage prise en compte
par les professionnels de santé dans
leur pré
tic et que la prévention et la promotion
de la santé devienne une part intégrante
des objectifs de nos politiques
publiques et des acteurs de notre
société civile je me réjouis
profondément de l'intérêt que suscite
cette approche au sein de votre
assemblée
je crois que nous pouvons partager
collectivement et de façon transparente
izan dans cet hémicycle la volonté d'un
changement de méthode d'une ambition
renouvelée pour la politique de santé et
je dirais même d'un réel changement de
paradigme dans la conduite des
politiques publiques
ce plfss comporte comme vous le savez
deux mesures très fortes et emblématique
de cette démarche nous souhaitons rendre
obligatoire pour les jeunes enfants 11
vaccin qui était jusqu'à présent pour
huit d'entre eux simplement recommandés
nous ne pouvons pas accepter une
situation où des personnes des enfants
sont victimes de maladies qui peuvent
être évités par la vaccination
70 à 80% des enfants français reçoivent
déjà ses onze vaccin ce n'est donc pas
un bouleversement majeur des habitudes
et des attitudes vaccinale mais ce taux
est malheureusement insuffisant pour
obtenir une couverture vaccinal efficace
il est qu'il laisse la possibilité que
se développent des situations
épidémiques qui ont des conséquences
graves
il revient donc à la puissance publique
de prendre ses responsabilités
vacciner son enfant c'est le protéger
mais c'est aussi protéger les autres et
je vais insister sur la dimension
profondément solidaire et altruiste de
ce geste de la vaccination
ce plfss porte également une hausse très
importante des prix du tabac sur trois
ans avec une première étape
significative dès 2018 de 1 euro de plus
par paquet nous avons un problème
particulier avec le tabagisme
nos jeunes fument plus que dans les pays
voisins le tabagisme des femmes est
particulièrement élevé en france
le résultat c'est près de 80 mille morts
par an ce sont surtout des vies abréger
des souffrances importantes que l'on
pourrait éviter je l' ai déjà dit il n'y
a pas plus de fatalité dans ces morts
qu'il n'y avait de fatalité dans la
mortalité sur nos routes
le prix du tabac c'est un fait constaté
documenté est un paramètre important du
comportement des fumeurs
il faut donc agir sur ce levier ce n'est
bien sûr pas le seul et je ferai
connaître dans le cadre du plan national
de santé les mesures de prévention et
d'incitation que je souhaite mettre en
place pour aider les fumeurs à s'arrêter
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de rappeler le
dialogue très constructif que j'ai eu
avec gérald darmanin pour progresser
vers cet objectif de santé publique
majeur
je veux affirmer devant vous non légale
détermination à soutenir la lutte contre
les marchés parallèles légaux ou
illégaux dans le cadre national comme
dans le cadre européen et à veiller à
l'échelon européen toujours à la mise en
place d'un système de traçabilité
efficace et indépendant l'assemblée
nationale a souhaité également avec un
soutien très large parmi les différentes
familles politiques faire évoluer la
taxation des boissons sucrées pour
inciter les producteurs à en faire
baisser la teneur en sucre
le gouvernement soutient cette
initiative et partage l'importance d'une
politique résolue et constantes visant
réduire l'obésité et le surpoids
la consommation de boissons sucrées est
un vecteur notable de la consommation
excessive en sucre notamment chez les
plus jeunes il m'apparaît dès lors
nécessaire et légitime de renforcer la
prise de conscience collective autour
des enjeux d'une alimentation équilibrée
et d'inciter les acteurs de ce secteur à
agir en ce sens je veux dire enfin mon
attachement à une meilleure prévention
du cancer dont j'ai souhaité renforcer
l'efficacité pour les jeunes femmes par
la voie d'un amendement au projet de loi
grâce à une consultation à l'âge de 25
ans gratuite
le deuxième axe de la stratégie
nationale de santé concerne l'égalité
d'accès aux soins
les français ils sont légitimement très
attachés c'est le fondement de notre
modèle social
je vais m'attacher à améliorer
concrètement l'accès aux soins les
difficultés d'accès aux soins sont
d'abord liés au montant des restes à
charge
c'est en particulier vrai de longue date
dans trois domaines du soin l'optique le
dentaire et les audioprothèses ou
l'assurance maladie couvre moins bien la
dépense ou les assureurs complémentaires
parfois pris le relais mais où
globalement le reste à charge pour le
patient est très élevé cette situation
est le fruit de l'histoire d'arbitrage
successifs qui ont conduit à créer des
angles morts de la protection sociale
pour des soins ou des prestations qui
rendent pourtant un service important
aux patients et réduisent la bascule
notamment dans la dépendance
il n'y a pas de fatalité à ce qu'il en
soit toujours ainsi
c'est pourquoi c'est pourquoi j'ai
commencé le travail et la concertation
pour aboutir à un reste à charge 0 dans
les domaines de l'optique et des
audioprothèses en sus des négociations
entamées mi septembre dans le secteur
dentaire ces travaux devront aboutir en
tout état de cause avant la fin du
premier semestre 2018
mais permettez moi dans ce contexte
d'évoquer le tiers payant
vous le savez le rapport de l'igas qui
m'a été remis a conclu que la
généralisation du tiers payant à la date
du 30 novembre tel que le prévoyait la
loi du 26 janvier 2016 était irréaliste
j'en ai tiré les conclusions en
proposant au parlement de lever cette
obligation
le tiers payant restera bien entendu
obligatoires là où ils s'appliquent déjà
et où il fonctionne bien c'est à dire
pour les personnes souffrant d'une
affection de longue durée
prise en charge à 100 % on a aidé les
femmes enceintes ou les bénéficiaires de
la cmu c et de l'aide à la
complémentaire santé
mais je vais vous dire également mon
attachement à ce que le tiers payant se
généralise pour les consultations
médicales comme cela a été le cas pour
les médicaments et ma détermination à
faire aboutir les travaux qui
permettront de rendre le système simple
d'utilisation pour les professionnels le
gouvernement s'est engagé à présenter au
parlement d'ici le 31 mars un calendrier
de déploiement opérationnel du tiers
payant intégral dans des conditions
techniques fiabiliser à cette date nous
identifierons également des publics
prioritaires au delà des publics déjà
couverts pour lesquels un accès effectif
aux tiers payant intégral devrait être
garantie nos concitoyens sont également
préoccupés de plus en plus par l'égal
accès aux soins sur le territoire et je
sais la haute assemblée fortement
mobilisés sur cette question
j'ai présenté le 13 septembre dernier
avec le premier ministre un plan pour
renforcer l'égal accès aux soins
le constat que nous pouvons faire c'est
que nous n'avons pas su assez anticipé
l'évolution de l'exercice médical des
attentes des nouvelles générations de
médecins et surtout le fait que
l'évolution du profil des patients
nécessitent une prise en charge par des
équipes de soins
composée de médecins mais également
d'autres professionnels de santé je ne
crois pas à la coercition et à
l'obligation il n'y a pas une solution
unique aux difficultés que vivent nos
concitoyens mais des solutions adaptées
à chaque territoire est porté par les
acteurs de terrain il faut promouvoir
l'innovation en santé dans les
territoires comme l'a préconisé le
rapport des sénateurs car d'où est donné
et d'aubigny donner à ces acteurs de
terrain le maximum de possibilités
d'organisation libérer du temps médical
en levant les freins administratifs en
favorisant notamment le cumul
emploi-retraite les remplacements
les consultations avancées l'exercice
coordonnées sous toutes ses formes
c'est le sens du plan d'action que nous
avons bâti et qui devra continuer à être
enrichi avec la contribution des élus au
cours de la mandature en appui de ce
plan le plfss porte la générale
généralisation de l'usagé de la
téléconsultation et de la télé expertise
en les sortant de leur cadre
expérimental s'agissant maintenant de
l'innovation et de la pertinence des
soins je veux en particulier facilité
l'expérimentation de formes
d'organisation et de rémunération
nouvelle
elles permettront de dépasser les
logiques sectorielle ville hôpital de
rémunérer par exemple au forfait des
séquences de soin de prendre en compte
la prévention de prendre en compte
également la pertinence des actes
réalisés
je vous proposerai donc d'adopter à
l'article 35 de ce projet un cadre
général valable pour le quinquennat qui
permettra de lancer et d'évaluer ces
expérimentations
ces expérimentations pour être lent
financé par don par un fonds
d'innovation qui sera abondé
tant que de besoin par l'assurance
maladie mon objectif à terme est bien de
faire évoluer et de compléter les
dispositifs actuels de rémunération
rémunération à l'acte ou tarification à
l'activité
je suis en effet convaincu de ce que le
levier tarifaire est un levier
fondamental de l'évolution de notre
système de santé vers plus de prévention
vers plus de coopération entre
professionnels et vers plus de
pertinence des soins je sais monsieur le
président milon monsieur le rapporteur
général que nous partageons la même
perception de ce que la pertinence des
soins est un enjeu majeur pour notre
système de santé
je veux vous dire ma disponibilité pour
travailler deux concerts à ce que les
professionnels et les organisations
prennent mieux en compte cet objectif je
veux terminer maintenant en évoquant
l'évolution de la dépense d'assurance
maladie ondam l'ondam sera fixée à 2 3%
ce taux est conforme à l'engagement du
président de la république il est
supérieur à celui des trois années
précédentes et il va permettre de
consacrer 4 4 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires à la couverture des
soins
ce taux prend en compte les engagements
déjà souscrit dont la convention
médicale signée en 2016
l'impact de cette convention important
en 2017
le sera plus encore en 2018 c'est
pourquoi le sous-objectifs des soins de
ville sera supérieur au taux global dont
dame et veut évaluée à 2 4 %
j'estime que cette convention va dans le
sens des orientations que je porte
elle valorise mieux l'action des
généralistes et prend mieux en compte
notamment les actes complexes ou
réalisés dans des situations d'urgence
l'évolution des ressources des
établissements de santé sera pour sa
part à 2,2 pour cent du fait de l'apport
que constituera pour les établissements
de santé le relèvement de 2 euros du
forfait journalier 400 millions d'euros
seront dédiés à l'investissement
immobilier et numérique
près de 600 millions d'euros seront
consacrés à l'augmentation des dépenses
de la liste en sus lié à l'arrivée de
nouvelles classes thérapeutiques
innovantes
plus de 200 millions de mesures
nouvelles
permettront de mettre des actions
indispensables dans le cadre de nos
politiques publiques par exemple pour
mieux faciliter l'accès aux soins des
populations précaires
enfin le fonds d'intervention régional
le firent sera augmenté de 3,1 pour cent
le fir doit être avec le fonds
d'innovation que j'évoquais précédemment
le support d'une politique de
transformation au plus près du terrain
un taux dont damas 2,3 pour cent reste
un taux exigeant il doit nous inviter à
poursuivre la réorganisation de notre
offre de soins et à orienter toujours
plus notre notre offre de santé vers la
pertinence
plusieurs dispositions du plfss vous
propose des actions en ce sens nous
devons également pour les prestations de
santé comme sur l'ensemble du champ de
la sécurité sociale être vigilant pour
détecter juguler la fraude
ce projet de loi fait également des
propositions en la matière pour conclure
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs nous
avons voulu dans ce premier plfss
donner du sens et donner des
perspectives donner du sens c'est mettre
en oeuvre pour nos concitoyens des
réformes concrètes c'est aussi faire des
choix donner des perspectives s'est
engagé des réformes en profondeur et
bouger les lignes pour faire progresser
notre collectivité nationale
je vous remercie merci madame la mini